Speaker 1: We've got a voicemail
number two. One nine two David P..
Here's a great voicemail, but it
actually there's something sad in it,
I have to tell you. Take a listen to this,
Speaker 4: Mr. Pacman Aaron from Boise. Yeah,
I heard your show today, and I just wanted
to say that you missed your calling as a.
Impersonator, you're Alex Jones
was off the charts. My friend.
Speaker 1: So listen, we we can't find my
impression. I recently did an impression of Alex
Jones. I remember doing it where I was saying, you
know, doing the whole that weird, conspiratorial
lisp, the frogs and all that stuff. We can't
find it. I don't remember. Did I do it on a
live stream? Did I do it in a YouTube clip? If
you know where that Alex Jones impression is,
we want to clip it. We think it would do
well on social media. We just can't find
it. So please let me know. Speaking of Alex
Jones, he's been found liable for defamation
in the Sandy Hook hoax case. We're going
to talk about that on today's bonus show
and so many other great stories. Sign up at join
Packman dot com. I'll see you on the bonus that.